c'est la love machine c'est vraiment
faire il ya deux capteurs qui sont
reliés à bout tous et qui sont reliés
voilà en bluetooth à un écran vous le
dis on va mettre les mains et on va voir
notre compatibilité ça marche
d'accord attention les divines et elle
s'est parée est ce que c'est bon leur
origine et attend elle est posée mettez
bien vaudois isabelle isabelle avec
l'europe à régler
alors nous on a ces morts de chez moi
non mais rien faire du tout dans les
vieux pots la partie bas les choses en
main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attendez je veux voir déjà 80 pour soi
baba calme toi c'est que tu prêt à temps
et martin 3,4 à dire zéro
[Applaudissements]
ça rigolait pour l'instant c'est
benjamin castaldi
je vous dis je ferai à celui qui non non
non ça c'est benjamin et dieu sait que
ça m'arrange pas dieu sait que ça marche
c'est par tina les metal impose c'est
bloquer le ballon et faire comme the
bread aisle mettez votre main vous avez
mangé des boulettes avant la beauté du
salon vers elle à larissa sur les
massacres
ça marche pas bosser des prix cassés ou
quoi bon allez on y va
elle a mangé des chaussures aux tons sur
ma vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attendez attendez ça n'est pas une image
à lui cherché dans la course au corps
mais je sais maintenant il est à
terminer par kelly on sait jamais eu un
jean-michel d'accord je passais le pire
je veux pas c'est bien pour l'instant
beinheim suis très content 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elles sont pas d'augmentation je vous
dis ça me rassure et franchement
jean-luc on a 80 ans ça ne devrait pas
nous amadouer mais ça devrait poser
moto2 moi ça ne veut rien dire ça
sous-entend que moi je vous aime pas
c'est parti pour l'instant c'est belaiba
77 jamais tu sais ce que tu peux compter
et c'est franchement on va leur dire
cessé mes deux plus proches c'est ça les
chinois jamais eu des amis je vous aime
beaucoup les autres et on l'a fait oui
oui vous allez faire avec max payne
alors avec max s'il n'y a plus de 50%
entre vous deux après le mach 3 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
photo du loup alors allez y les lis j'ai
beaucoup de points communs avec fatou à
ça m'arrange pas jose marti 3 2 1
[Applaudissements]
la musique est ma maison qui les lie et
maxime après l'ascension bbd ce but
n'est pas de se moquer des français
orrick attention c'est parti
ce sens le dos ou non et les mois sont
pas du tout absolument pas alors
mesdames
non
lalonde
aulas le monde
alors que
c'est maxime guémy si l'on va faire
d'avoir maxime
[Applaudissements]
je l'attends magie c'est vraiment le
calcul est alors ça rigolait elle a
l'air ce scientifique c'est vrai ici
c'est sûr alors bas mais en tout cas
merci d'être là ce avait servi ce que
c'est que la complicité la compatibilité
c'est qu'on m'a dit moi non alors il ya
des projets comme un projet qu'on va
passer en tunisie
y'a de la connexion intellectuelle 1 on
est on adore castanier la connexion
émotionnelle c'est dire que vous
ressentez vous refroidir la connexion de
sexuel
[Rires]
c'est là on aura zéro et de la connexion
spirituelle c'est à dire vous avez quand
même des valeurs qui vous rassemble à
l'héroïne pendant là beaucoup c'est sûr
ça va faire 100%
allez vas y j'adore ce qu'il fait comme
ça basi on y va prévenez après moi très
vénérés après moi vous êtes formidable
mais je vous aime beaucoup pouvaient
rester toute l'émission et doux à huy a
été clair un truc ou alors on va la
prendre on parle d'un truc
une émission qui marche pas on parle
d'amour bonsoir je suis moi deux minutes
jouées en forêt dominés devant forêt car
exempt de minutes merci attention c'est
parti
concentre toi c'est pas un fan de fer
s'est fait un nom face aux marquis la
main les plus grosses que la table
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maxime est clean or la la ça leur temps
aux l'anis il faut plus de 50% rien ce
match oui bien sûr à bosse mâles dans
l'émission allez on n'est pas là pour ça
et ça devient payant n'est pas
dégueulasse alexis jours c'est plus
drôle de voir un sommet contre vous
étiez lien page et se cache ta joie
y a vraiment personne qui veut se moquer
kelly à la peau et elle est très belle
et pas indisponible
on peut tout à fait avoir des coupes qui
partent sur une compatibilité 0 3% et
qui finalement n'en reviennent de
manière mathématique
donc je te dis tu gardé son bébé dans
mes cheveux gris personne va se marier
personnes on va voir si un maxime gagné
et toi ça fait plus de cela car et après
on en reparlera mais choqué c'est la
part avec moi merci à eux
tu pars au campus juste à pedro
[Applaudissements]
publiquement savoir qui veut dire d'agde
et postaux fait là le gavage c'est bon
t'as des bonnes mains merci mais je
préfère tes mains c'est beau ac on en
est au niveau du boulevard des millions
de personnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à